hello friends I'm Alana welcomed by
China wet today I am sort of giving you
a review of it chapter two while also
playing remedies new game control
because whatever reason when I talk
about movies in TV I also like to be
playing a video game helps me focus or
something so I got to see an early
screening of it chapter two a couple of
weeks ago and there are things that I
like about it and things I don't like
about it so much as is with most things
the one thing that really stands out to
me though is that I did not find this
movie as scary as chapter one I did not
find chapter two as scary and at first I
was like I get that some of the themes
in this movie a lot more haunting a lot
more devastating there's some really
extreme homophobia there's some really
extreme domestic abuse like stuff that's
just really unsettling because it's real
and that comes with it being an adult
version when it comes to actual fiha I
didn't find it as scary I did find it
really creative and the things that
Pennywise does to scare the losers Club
is exciting to watch for sure but then I
sort of figured out the theme and
realized that the reason it's not as
scary is a good one if that makes sense
so of course I'm just assuming you've
seen it chapter one because you have to
have and I will try to avoid spoilers in
this video but basically it chapter two
is about all of these adults who have
gone their separate ways and they've
left dairy and they've actually
forgotten about
Pennywise except for Mike who stayed in
dairy and it's contacting everyone to
bring them out together because it's
been 27 years awful things are happening
and dairy again because Pennywise is
back they all get the phone calls and
they stop to slowly remember and as they
get back to dairy they remember more and
more and thus guys do start pretty much
immediately they don't shy away from
making the adult losers Club hallucinate
it's just that the hallucinations seem
kind of silly and I know some people
were worried about this because they
were concerned that with adults it
couldn't possibly be as scary as it
could be with kids or that they wouldn't
even try because obviously the losers
Club has the context of Pennywise
they've seen him before they've been
through it before but what actually
ended up happening is more along the
lines of when the kids returned to Derry
or when the losers Club returned to
Derry
the way that I took it they basically
revert to their child cells so you're
watching adults become their child
versions again
Eddie's such a good example of an actor
who plays the kid actor just perfectly
and there is a shift from when you see
them as adults in their own lives
to when you see them as adults in dairy
who again acting like children and it
seems like maybe a little bit more like
children as time goes on so these adults
confronting that childhood traumas that
is what this movie is about is the fact
that you have to confront childhood
trauma you have to get through it you
can't just run away from it or it will
eat you alive and that is totally a
theme in this film in fact that is the
the piece that holds the film together
and I think that that is very powerful
they could have gone dumb horror movie
but they did stay true to the source
material there too obviously I can't
give don't make his credit from things
that happened in a book a long time ago
but basically they revert to their child
selves like I said and as a part of that
they they are afraid of things that
children would be afraid of that even me
as an adult watching it I was not
particularly afraid of like a scary old
lady or a statue that comes to life or
chums or whatever else and because of
that it kind of automatically has a
little bit of funny element but I do
think that a lot of the humor is
intentional I tweeted right after I sold
a movie that it chapter 2 was my
favorite comedy of 2019 and I didn't
mean that as an insult it's very funny
Bill Hader is very funny but I think
that just the setting of these adults
being afraid of the things they were
afraid of as children makes for a lot of
comedic really and it's not for no
reason because again I think that it's
all wrapped up in that theme which is
getting rid of childhood trauma facing
that trauma even as an adults and
actually walking through it which is
done in various ways in the movie some
of those ways seem a little bit silly
and like weirdly video game II but I
feel like I just wanted to make this
video where I usually wouldn't review a
movie here I would leave it for the
funhouse film podcast film house which
will have a way longer version
of an interview I just really didn't
want to talk about this one thing
because I feel like when the movie comes
out some people probably won't click
with them because it definitely did not
click with me immediately what was
happening which is like I said adults
dealing with that childhood fears and
walking through those traumas because
they have to because if they don't
Pennywise will will eat them alive and
you know because of the way the losers
Club is in the fact that they have to
work together a lot of that is you know
you can read into that that you need a
support network to deal with that
childhood trauma etc etc there's a lot
of stuff you can read into to all of
this really it must seem weird for
anyone who hasn't seen this out of
control but I'm not reacting to the
insane stuff that happens in this game
but I have played the start of this game
multiple times I promise this game is
great if you like Alan Wake or max payne
no quantum break same developers if you
didn't know that so they make good stuff
but yeah the fact that they're acting
like children throughout the course of
the movie or at least that's how I read
it is that they are acting like the the
child versions of themselves as soon as
they get back to to Derry
does mean that inherently it is a funny
a film but of course it's also the damn
performances in writing it is written
intentionally with jokes
I don't think calling it funny is an
insult it just probably is a little bit
harder to make it scary when what
they're doing is inherently funny
childish silly etc but of course with a
purpose and I like that about it I found
that that fact are really charming while
I don't think it's as good as the first
movie I don't think it's as impactful as
the first movie I don't think it's as
concise or as tight as the first movie I
have some issues with some of the
chemistry I didn't really buy that these
these people liked each other that much
even though obviously they have spent a
lot of time apart and I've in theory
changed you know they revert to their
childhood selves when they go back there
so I think I wanted them to revert in
relationships as well but they don't and
yeah the pacing is off it's also just
it's it's really hard to follow the
first movie and I don't feel like
they're ever gonna follow it up
perfectly when that movie is a
self-contained story whereas this one
relies on the first one you have to have
seen the first one if you haven't I mean
it will also just give you a ton of
flashbacks but because it depends so
heavily on something else it is
derivative
of that story and can't really stand
alone as an amazing piece and I get that
but for what it ultimately tried to do
which is you know have several adult
actors who look exactly the same as the
childhood counterparts which would have
been difficult in itself and then to
also you know wrap up a story that
basically already wrapped itself up with
a pot - that again is tackling that
theme that is still so related to their
childhoods I feel like there was no way
this maybe did the same as the book ever
could have been quite as good as as part
one and I feel like while there are
absolutely scary moments I'm not gonna
I'm not going to kid you there are parts
of the movie that are scary there are
things that look horrific and sound
horrific and it's it gets very visually
creative and dramatic I'm not telling
you it's not scary at all I just didn't
think that I was as scared as I was
watching the first movie but even for
that that that lack of feel at least for
me
maybe people when they see it will feel
differently about it I feel like it made
up for it in in the trauma of having a
meeting having a point forcing these
characters to walk through the things
that they were afraid of and you
visually see them do that and but to
children when they do that and that's
the power that they have the Pennywise
is that they're strong and they stop
being afraid I just really like the
theme that's why I wanted to talk about
it because I don't I just don't know how
the public the general movie going
public is gonna react to this film I'm
very curious to see but I don't know if
I've said it already Bill hader's
performance is incredible he I think is
officially my favorite actor I was
toying with it for a while he's amazing
in skeleton twins and very good and
berry and amazing in this it's cause God
as Pennywise is also fantastic he's so
good there are a lot of just like
fantastic moments just a lot of
entertainment top to bottom it's a very
fun film despite the fact that it is
definitely flawed and I think I'm just
willing to forgive a lot of the flaws
because I think that it uh execute on
its vision very well because it's vision
is so hype a specific that had to be
challenging and there was no way it was
gonna be easy to make this movie or easy
to make it better than chapter one I
feel like that's actually
possible there are some things that I
probably would have cut even though they
were in the books because they feel a
little bit out of place or don't feel
like they have much of a point and of
course there are some things that are in
the books that didn't make the movie and
vice-versa
I don't think any of that will
disappoint people too much though
so yeah is this Randy I have no idea I
just wanted to talk about it because
they again I really like that angle of
it and I think this is pretty much how
I'll always do any time but I talk about
TV or movies which I said I don't do a
lot but if I do this will be the format
that I do it in where I'm just kind of
chatting so thank you for watching my it
chapter 2 review everyone and watching
me play the side of control for the
thousandth time serious lose game is
really good though I'm Alana and I will
see you guys next time bye